[Music]
joining me today is a lawyer a gun
rights activists and the host of no are
on NRA TV colleano are welcome to the
Rubin report how's it going man how's it
going my friend it's going good it's
good to be in LA I am I'm glad to have
you know we've been trying to do this
for about a year
yeah yeah yeah I just like to think so
yeah it might just be a facade I put on
to avoid people but now and actually but
in reality now it's it's been it's been
a pretty busy year yeah like extremely
so and it doesn't ever seem to slow up
and just what I think it does something
else jumps off well if you think coming
on this show is gonna help slow it down
you are sorely mistaken
yeah well I'm a bit of a masochist in
that regard we'll see by the time this
hour is done work on earth hell we can
write I'm pretty sure there will be some
yeah well don't worry because there will
be equal amounts on me just for a
sitting here with you that's the
interesting thing
you know I it's I don't want to say I've
been blind to it but just being just
seeing some of the reaction and
responses that I got especially for
instance when I was on Maher when I did
Bill Maher you know I saw some of the
comments from I say the other side just
for ease of communication yeah but for
people who largely don't agree with me
in his audience they were like I would
drop the NRA guy on there even a I was a
tweet I responded to yesterday and even
though I was on my no tweeting do that I
like to put myself on because so toxic
in there sometimes how often do you do
that
happy 30 minutes I'm trying to do
weekends and disappearing at all of
August see it man
Twitter's toxic man when you're in the
lane that you and I are in yeah it's
toxic man and it can really even though
you don't think you're taking that in
even just kind of scrolling through
you're taking it in yeah you know and in
it it's like I constantly I developer
this pattern of just yeah don't respond
to that cuz they're baiting you yeah I
mean things of that nature but um I was
I saw a tweet and she's like yeah I
loved Omar oh I love this episode but
you have that NRA guy on it I'm like
Jesus are we not allowed to have
discourse anymore
if especially if it disagrees with with
something that you believe in oh and you
know like this is a very
we're going down if that's good if
that's gonna be the case because you
forget you know we live in this country
together yeah and we're not all the same
there's about 350 million other yeah
might not all think the same thing
exactly pretty crazy it's it's kind of
sad some it will least for me it's a
little disheartening yeah because I grew
up under the guise and understanding the
importance of discourse and being able
to talk things out even if you do
disagree with someone but didn't even
still having the ability to set aside
whatever views I may have on a
particular issue and then be able to
speak of you cordially or have respect
for you even though we don't agree
that's the way I was brought up in so to
see the country kind of falling into
this extremely of erotic divisiveness it
it's a hardening yeah you know I don't
wanna get all emo on you you don't have
to guess cried till the end but that's
exactly why I wanted to have you on
because you you are okay going into
enemy territory I'm not on this enemy
turns yeah but you did you did Mars show
where you knew a certain percentage of
the audience was just gonna hate you
yeah and we talked about it briefly
right before we started but you found
Maher to be basically pretty pretty
respected even kill yeah okay even
though I'm policy he probably disagrees
with you with 8080 pretty much yeah and
you know and it was something that I
ended up respecting about him and in
that regard cos like I said I I kind of
I went in prepared for I didn't go in to
do war but I went and prepared for it
you know it was like prepared for the
worst hope for the best and I tell you I
got the best in a sense of it was a it
was a discourse where he challenged me
but it wasn't this kind of tumultuous
kind of flooding of the heads where it
just turned into something that was just
ugly yeah well he wasn't trying to get
yet yeah trying to understand you
because that that you know I'm trying to
do that here I there's a couple other
places where people are trying to do
that but yeah that's the thing that's
been lost and that's an interesting
thing you point out there it's I think
sometimes people take offense to that
idea it's like I don't your intruder
intriguing I think intrigue kind of
offends people sometimes because it's
like we all grow up with a typical
understanding what we expect certain
people to be like and then when certain
things don't fit it's like that's
interesting how did you get there right
and I think when it's innocent like that
I don't think there's an issue there
when you use it to try to kind of muscle
people into believing a certain thing
based on what they are then that's when
we start having problems you know what I
mean it's like you see me it's like how
do you as a black guy like it happened
to me when I first started doing what I
did with the NRA Russell Simmons and
I'll never forget this I was like I was
like in Virginia Beach I think and
Russell said I I did my first sets of
videos and rolled out with the NRA and I
get this tweet from Russell Simmons and
he's like how can you as a young black
man push Daddy you get you know the
typical rhetoric in that regard even
though he often is all about trying to
get people to exactly which is really
yeah and so I responded I said you know
like I didn't know advocating for self
defense and self-reliance was a bad
thing I didn't know that only non black
people are allowed to do that right and
so that was kind of like my first foray
into that world of wait a minute people
have an expectation of me based on my
race that I'm not gonna say I was
oblivious to but it just when it was
coming from people that look like me as
well with the same level of intensity
that's when I go WOW okay alright so
here that's what this is yeah okay so I
won I want to back up to a little bit of
childhood and growing up because you're
evolutions kind of dream but let's just
say with this for one second because I
think there's something really
interesting about that thing right there
that often if you listen to the media
they'll tell you that police are hunting
down black men and all of this and then
at the same time you're saying well we
should be able to arm ourselves and
protect ourselves from the white
supremacist but meaning that lawfully
and legally we should be able to take
care of ourselves if you believe that
the system is so corrupt and the police
are so corrupt and there's racists
running around everywhere you're trying
to bring the power back to yourself
that's to me that's very empowering yet
somehow this seemingly is lost when this
conversation hits the mainstream it's
amazing I don't understand it it's like
in one breath you're talking about let's
let's take the colonel ministration for
instance
paint it as this the most vicious and
vile thing on a planet and then it's
like well then let's give the same guns
that you have for your own self reliance
I would you would use to protect
yourself against this monster that you
said existed and let's give it to them
and then place your entire reliance with
respect to your safety on the same
people you you're telling me I should be
scared of it doesn't you're horrible
give them your weapons what it's it's
mind-blowing right and so what it does
though it exposes this notion that the
there's a absence of ability to I don't
say mobility or people just choosing not
to critically think mm-hmm you know and
we're at a point now where we have
access and that's like it amazes me some
of the questions that I get and it's
like you literally have a device that
gives you access to all of the
information in the world in the case of
my overabundant ass I have two of them
right and it's like it takes you to
follow I assume you have like eight guns
on you at all right yeah you know and
it's it's amazing how when we have such
access to so much information we've
become so lazy at reaching for it this
was almost like back in the day when we
didn't have this access we we more
adamant about search searching and
seeking it out and critically thinking
about things it's almost we become too
fast for our own good right so the
obsession now is instant information
into the information regardless of
whether or not the information is of any
use or good or the or if it's even
correct yeah you know and so it's it
hate it because you know I logged I've
done all of those things and I actually
people get mad at me when I don't jump
on a certain issue quick enough and when
I say cook enough within 30 seconds I'll
see that sometimes it goes down in the
news and a literally two minutes go by
or I'm at dinner and I wasn't looking my
phone and then I'll get a slew of tweets
people I see you didn't comment on he
must be in on it
good god paid off god forbid it involves
a black person and there's a gun within
10 miles I have to jump on it yeah you
know and in their some cases I
understand there are some people who do
who are just now getting into this who
are just now getting in the fire
and they are black right and you know
maybe they look to me for understanding
and direction because I've been doing it
for so long so that I understand but but
other people it's just this constant
desire to be like ah ha I got you I knew
you were [ __ ] the kind of deal right and
it's like like give me 30 seconds to
even read the article you just sent me
ten seconds ago yeah right and then from
there and then not to mention you know
there's a thing called work that I do
so yeah I'm still doing that as well so
I'm you know I'm juggling a lot of
things I don't have to tell you you
probably 310 more articles to even
ascertain anything close to the truth
bingo and that's the one thing that I I
think a lot of people don't do and I
almost tweeted that the other day I go
you know it's very dangerous to read
headlines especially in the day and age
of clickbait titles to just read
headlines and then make an opinion based
off of that or think you know understand
what happened in a particular story
because there are so many articles that
I've read about me yeah and what I've
said where the headline said one thing
and to cover their asses within the
article they'll clarify exactly what
that what it is that I said but they're
banking on the idea that people are just
gonna read the headlines and then run
with that yeah and so it ends up making
a fool of you fool of people what's your
personal policy on that about how to
respond to that do you go all in on the
fight do you ignore it because I this
has happened to me not just in the last
week and daily be said I was an all
right cheerleader you're black I think
so how am i doing for the fur and all
right you you suck well no I mean but
this is the level of pity but but then
it's about how much time do you want to
invest in in defending yourself and by
doing that defense do you just add
intensity to the people going hi see we
can get him to defend himself and then
before you know your whole life is
dedicated to defending yourself from
fake attacks rather than doing the work
that you care about two things one
you're they do the teachers are
dangerous
you're dangerous not because you agree
with me in certain certain issues you're
dangerous in the fact that you're just
simply willing to talk to me
so for it's the same thing happened when
I did I did the interview with killer
Mike mmm-hmm
right they jumped all over him not
because of what he said
but just because he sat down I had the
conversation with me yeah half the time
they don't even listen oh that's that's
interesting you point it out because I'm
like how can anyone watch this interview
and not walk away with saying you know
that was a great conversation about two
people who don't agree on everything but
there's some things we agree on he's
like because they didn't watch it that
sounds like what do you mean it's like I
had just this weird blonde moment right
yeah I'm like what do you mean he's like
he didn't watch it he's like they don't
actually watch the video they just read
the title and then assume they know what
happened in the video and then make
their opinion from there yeah I'm like
Danny right I hate going down the weeds
with too much of this because it feels
like we're just responding to all of the
craziness but even in the evenin like
the YouTube ecosystem yeah when we put
videos up sometimes within 10 seconds
there's a hundred comments that was an
hour I want that time machine because I
would be a lot more productive but it's
always the haters that do it that's why
I want to bring it up cuz it because
then that hate is the thing that's
always leading us and then I think that
brings it back to where you started a
moment ago which is that we're in this
polarized thing and because the haters
are sort of paving the road and everyone
else is just going down the road I think
a few of us are actually trying to find
a better Road that more of us can get I
the interesting thing about the
discourse the way it is now right and so
our politics have become our
entertainment that's the one that's the
dangerous aspect right so if it's not
vitriolic if it's not snarky if it's not
any of those things it people don't pay
attention to it and I'm the biggest
advocate of light all right look if you
if you don't agree with me on something
you're not to be an ass about it yeah
right now can I be snarky yeah no I can
absolutely be snarky but what I what I
tried to do to respond to your initial
question you asked him how do I like how
do I go all-in do I respond so like for
instance on Twitter what I've kind of
held myself back to doing now is if I
can tell that the person is later he's
seeking out an answer or response that's
I'm gonna give them that same energy in
terms of okay no let's let's have that
conversation right because there was a
point in time where everything I
responded to when I would spawn to it
through the lens of just being this
snarky has you know what I mean
and yeah sure was i entertaining myself
absolutely yeah but didn't I had to ask
myself was I really moving in
conversation in the dialogue along even
though it is Twitter right it's 20 it's
a dumpster fire right but what I started
has some importance it does just the
truth that's why it keeps coming up in
so many of these conversations we got
high-level people with great minds that
are open and engaging that are still
involved in the stupidity of that so
it's like when I bring it up with the
guests noise like I don't want to touch
that again and then on the other hand we
all know it's real it just it just is
whether we want it to be or not
everybody said whether we like not just
the meaning of expression right now and
so we have to you know it's like you
either adapt to die yeah but you know
it's it's I try I try to be what it is I
I tried to be the opposite of what I
could plane about at least I try in
terms of like sometimes I'll see snarky
messages and then I'll respond by trying
to be reasonable I'll say okay I get it
you don't like me but answer this
question for me and I try to move the
dialogue along you know what is up
happening to gets deleted yeah almost
every single time
yeah the second you shed a little light
on it Congrats scatter yeah yep what is
the before we dive too much into your
past what is the thing that they're
criticizing you most for like you come
across to me as a pretty rational mm-hm
decent open guy you're trying to empower
yourself okay so what is it that they're
always going after you is is it that
thing that a black man shouldn't be for
guns I mean is it that's simply stupid
so I'm like so I don't not gonna be so
naive as to assume it's simply just
because I'm blacking them in the gun
yeah they're alright thing holds up
that's the part of it that's a big part
of it
it's just aligning myself an
organization that they seemingly that
they see as being a racist organization
that hates black people okay we're gonna
talk plenty about the internet right so
there's that element of it but then
there's there is also this idea that
being young black men that I'm supposed
to run from guns because of the
projected image that we've all had
forced down our throats with respect to
black men in firearms in this country
for decades
you know black man with a gun he's a
thug he's drug dealers and getting
banger
so now when I young attorney educated
open-minded and deal with respect to
different issues and then I'm pushing
the narrative of the Second Amendment it
sets off an explosive level of cognitive
dissonance and people who have what I
love this quote and I believe was Bush
who said it
this soft bigotry of low expectation
right and it they hate it I hate it the
same way they they hate you now because
you can't control someone who's willing
to think independently outside of what
is stereotypically expected of you right
and that's where the labels come in and
so it's like you go do progressive
you're liberal you know so forth wrong
but you still have that ability to step
outside of that and say you know what
let me mean okay I can see that
perspective that's dangerous for people
who want to control people so when I
want to control the way you think the
way you see yourself I cannot allow you
to develop an ability to think
independently on separate issues because
then I can't control you so if I if I
say you know what I can do everything
for you depend on me the last thing I
want you to do and understand is you
know what wait a minute you mean tell me
I can protect myself you mean to tell me
I don't have to depend on calling a cop
in order to come save me if someone does
try to break into my house because then
I can't control you
I can't own your vote because what the
gun has done from me and a lot of people
it serves as a catalyst for the
awakening of a lot of people to
understand you know what I can do more
for myself than I realize you know and
once that once that spark is set off
then a lot of things you start to
realize you know I don't you know what
maybe you know now that I'm holding
myself to a different level of
accountability maybe I might try to do
this on my own you know doesn't it just
feel good I mean putting aside I know a
lot of people are into facts over
feeling these days right Shapiro but
doesn't that statement right there that
that you can do more for yourself it
just feels good like making some power
back to yourself and going the
government or you whoever you are that
are not in charge of my life my
responsibility my livelihood my family
the rest of it it's the most
rating feeling in the world and I'm with
you I'm all about backs over feelings
and I mean it from the standpoint I
don't allow my feelings to dictate the
facts you know I do think feelings are
necessary right because we because
within the absence of them we just
become cold calculated creatures right
and we are still human we are getting
you know what I mean so it's like now at
least all right so you know when I talk
about the issue of firearms I do
Dibley try to inquire I was having a
discussion with a lady not too long ago
about just general firearm issues with
respect to her son all right who's the
young black man and I asked her you know
like the are you fearful of the idea of
him carrying a gun and so forth and so
on and I have to bring myself back when
I'm having a discussion with someone
like that because I don't have kids
right so yeah am i Godfather that yeah
so no however but it's not the same that
for a woman who has a son so I have to
be cognizant of that and understand what
goes into that when she's thinking about
whether or not she she's okay with him
owning a firearm and and then on top of
that having this idea that her son is
more likely to get killed by a cop
because he has a gun on him versus when
he doesn't you know and that's where the
feeling component comes in where it's
necessary I think you if you can't
sympathize with that then it makes you
dismissive and so then that person can't
relate to you then we can't have that
conversation yeah you know what I mean
and that comes from personal experience
absolutely because when I was reading
your bio there I mean there's really
interesting stuff about how you evolved
sort of politically and personally but
when you started getting into guns you
kind of had to hide it yeah from your
mom even so everyone little bit about
about growing up and then sort of your
kind of politics and then how do we have
we got so into gun gotcha so I I grew up
largely a closeted anti-gun ER I didn't
realize all sounds like gonna to the
world there was one present right I
wasn't kind of rapidly running running
out scream yeah I hate guns or anything
like that but when a woman was president
I remember there's one moment when I was
in college had a roommate when her
friends brought a gun over I was like
you need to get to hell on my part
get out of my apartment and um well had
a good friend of mine who randomly just
asked me hey do you want to go to range
never even thought about it and I've
even crossed my mind which is how I know
a lot of times I can decipher based on
certain comments whether or not
somebody's actually commenting from a
place of ignorance or a place of
understanding because I was that guy
never even thought about going to range
never thought about shooting a gun but
to tell you all the opinions in the
world why that's right and so when I
hear that rhetoric now I can usually
point it out and like you've never shot
before you've never even held a gun
before and so from that perspective we
went to the gun range and a shot for the
first time and I was hooked now I was
hooked not from a political standpoint
now what not even from an empowering oh
my god I can protect myself now
standpoint it was just pure fascination
with the mechanics the physics all of it
I'm very kind of like curious mind so
for me it was like kind of like this
like the idea that I'm launching a
projectile faster than the speed of
sound a little target like a hundred
yards away like that was awesome so
first shot you were her first shot
terrified the second side I was like
lovely that's a little bit second shot
all right right so from that perspective
that I just I follow that rabbit all the
way down the hole but it was like I said
it was more from a scientific mechanical
understanding of it then as time went on
then I started looking at it from more
intellectual second-amendment political
activist standpoint and then I started
my then the lawyer mind kicked it mm-hmm
and then and I started looking I'm like
I'm hearing something we could be during
the time period then that particular
time period we had a couple of pretty
big mass shootings that happened and so
I started paying it and so I'm now
paying attention more to the skylight
when you're thinking about buying a car
and you never see it on the road and
once you start thinking about buying you
can see it everywhere that's pretty much
what happened now so I'm like I'm
hearing the conversation about guns
everywhere now and I'm like no this is
making any sense logically like what
people are proposing it doesn't it was
so pure it wasn't like an agenda drums
like this doesn't make sense to me it's
like a window like a stick on a window
is not gonna stop somebody from bringing
a gun in just saying that is illegal
you mean the sign that says No
I mean the bad guys not gonna read the
sign to be like exactly go to the other
place right so that's kind of when I
started jumping into the more activist
advocate side of things with respect to
the Second Amendment yeah and when you
first got guns yeah you were literally
hiding them where I was from your mom
yeah cuz cuz cuz she was very much I
mean she was a single parent mom raising
black son she wanted to port every
stereotype on the planet right
my mom overcompensated with me
tremendously because she under she
understood in her mind the limitations
that come with being a woman raising a
man by herself
so she overcompensated so where it's
like usually typically have like mama's
boys who are just calling mom does
everything for this [ __ ] wash your own
clothes come here go do everything she
made me and I at the time I just thought
she was just being a mean mom all right
not realizing you know it was her
overcompensating from the stand point
it's like I got to make this - I got to
raise a man yeah right and so but so she
was trying to buck so I knew once I
started getting into guns no no cuz the
perception was black man with gun gang
banger right and you know she had some
insecurities in that she's like you know
like they're gonna come a point where
I'm not gonna be able to control this
kid I don't know who's gonna be doing
and so I didn't want to terrify her and
make her think that I was living some
nefarious lifestyle that she and it was
almost a way to protect her more than
was to hide it from my sake because I
didn't want her to feel like she
actually failed as a mother
and so I knew if she saw the ak-47 that
I had hidden under my bed in her mind
she knows nothing about guns all she
knows is what she sees in the media in
New York who touched upon before that
imagery is not positive so she comes
home sees ak-47 in bed she's oh my god
my son is a gay baby first he stayed
under the bed now you said in the bed is
there anything you want to tell me her
we talked about that lady
the irony behind it is I did this kind
of embarrassing cuz you know about
basketball fans I used to sleep with my
basketball oh yeah man yeah I ball was
life that was everything now you still
got any skills some some yeah I got some
I'm actually working on trying to for
the next NRA annual meetings put
together like a - a charity basketball
of it if you're down but I've never
slept with my guns down Freud all right
okay so so from that point when you
started getting okay with this now
you're exploring it as you said
intellectually yeah how long before you
were really an advocate for this stuff
because you always sort of wanted to
fight for something yeah I mean with you
here he was deaf net that's what I
wanted to do I wanted to be an advocate
I wanted to be in the courtroom
defending people that's that was my goal
like even to the detriment of my grades
like I focused more on like my mock
trial stuff when I was in law school
than I did my actual work like - like
school was right and I liked being the
voice for people I like being able to
speak to people who can articulate
certain things the way that maybe I can
and I never saw this coming the way that
they did but I'm doing exactly what I
always wanted to do and and for me with
the gun thing I remember being in like
I'd be in like class in law school and
the way they like the seats are
staggered they're like stadium seats
right so if I'm on my computer and
you're behind me you can see what I'm
doing on my computer and I gotta be in
class and like I'm researching guns and
stuff like that right yeah dude like
people and the thing is a lot of things
that were being said about me I didn't
even know about - later on people were
concerned yeah I really like goes like
no yeah he's like these crazies not you
know um I get it if you don't if you're
not into that kind of thing and you
don't follow it the idea of how being
passionate about something you perceive
to be a a tool that used for killing
people and only killing people it's
gonna seem to outdo you
but because I came to it so naturally so
organically without any of that
they just made sense in my mind I was so
unapologetic about it
so I got over being apologetic about it
that I didn't push it in people's faces
but you know there was there was even
etat like that's how my Instagram got
started was me separating so the people
who followed me up into that point you
know I had a girlfriend at the time was
like you know a lot of questions for
people you know think you can time to
tone down the gun stuff a little bit and
it was it was kind of an innocent you
know thing but I never led you said you
know forget it I'm just gonna set up a
whole nother page and now I'm just gonna
do all the gun stuff I want to do on
that page yeah
and now that's taken over I don't even
use the other one and I don't even know
if I remember the password but it's so
from there that's where things really
started taking off and then with the in
and then when I started cuz I started
doing gun reviews and so then from there
when I got into the political component
of it then I started talking doing my
commentary and the Nats when things
started really taking off alright so
let's do this I want to do gun 101 with
you okay all the things that we should
know about guns and then I want to do
the most common misconceptions about
guns because I think part of the issue
right now is every time something
happens every time there's a shooting
and half the people don't know anything
about guns on one hand half the people
then give you all of those
misconceptions it gets it confusing for
everybody and even the people who I
generally trust now I sense don't know
exactly what they're saying so I want to
do a video with you right now what every
time one of these incidences happen and
someone starts asking me this ask me
that I want to go I've got the thing
that I can point to with the answers so
let's do gun what don't walk on what do
we need to know about all right first of
all most a are does not stand for
assault rifle so when I say ar-15 that's
not assault rifle does not mean assault
rifle an assault rifle is a gun that is
fully automatic right that means I pull
the trigger I hold it back and it
expends all of the ammunition in the
magazine that's that's that's Jesse
Ventura in predator boom okay it's a
great gun yeah love that gun right I can
argue about not gonna side with mine
owning it
so okay so that's automatic yeah just
hold it down
and it will fire every round
subsequently until it's completely out
okay right and that's so at a very high
rate of speed
okay generally speaking somebody
automatic so there's been this thing
where people conflate this or use
semi-automatic as a kind of a hyperbolic
way of characterizing guns as death
killing machines right
virtually every modern gun is
semi-automatic and what that means is
one press of the trigger you get one
bullet versus holding the trigger down
once and getting all the bullets okay so
that's a great distinction out there
because often when this happens you you
see people saying we have to ban semi
automatics yes semi automatic that's
virtually every month so it's not
because all that the only difference
between that and a what a fully
automatic well what's one that you're
just loading one bullet in okay so that
would be a bolt-action okay right so
there's fully automatic semi-automatic
in bolt-action right right bolt action
more and more lines like like hunting
right or hyper high precision shooting
and it's a both because it allows you to
build the gun up in such a way where you
it's the tighter constraints within a
gun and it allows you to be more
accurate okay without certain mechanism
moving back and forth causing throwing
off the accuracy of the shot so you
would say then that when when all of
these people come out and say we have to
ban semi automatics that they are
actually just flat-out confused or
intentionally conflating or obfuscating
what the truth is related to them yes
absolutely and so it's either the
confused ignorant or they're doing the
purpose for like you just stated okay so
what is the so let's do some nra stuff
while while we're doing this
what is the nra stance on automatics
just being able to hold and shoot i mean
the way it's currently regulated is the
way it's danced like right now there's
like in order to get an automatic gun
there's a certain process you have to go
through in order to get them and and
that it's been that way for a very long
time now and that's been that it exists
yeah as it does now and that's
essentially war where the stance is it
with respect to fully automatic gun well
what are people using fully automatic
guns for so because I think this is
where you hear people go well no one
needs an automatic to hunt well see his
thing no it's
it's the idea of putting it under the
guise of needing write their name
another write where we use that same
standard you know it begs the question
that so it's like okay you have a fully
automatic gun and you have
semi-automatic guns a bolt-action there
are different reasons why you would want
each of these guns now I can delve into
that but then that starts getting into
the very nerdy side of firearm ownership
where the enthusiast aspect of that
comes into it it's understanding
tactically why you would want certain
things and so for me I'm not personally
I don't have a problem with people on
the fully automatic guns personally I
just don't see that as a significant
danger above and beyond say owning a
nuclear suitcase right so if people
tried to make that absurd argument to me
before it's like well then why don't you
be loved and well that's because there's
there's a cost-benefit ratio that
doesn't make any sense all right that
you just that's inherently
self-destruction
so how is this how is that protecting
you in any way from the very thing that
you're supposed to be checking yourself
against do you think there should be a
higher threshold to be able to get an
automatic than some of the other weapons
you're talking about me personally
threshold in what respect like in terms
of either hire back graded background
checks or references so let's talk about
background checks every minute so
there's this i dentist notion that we
don't have background checks for our
guns we do and a funny thing is we in
the gun community we have become a
victim of technology and what I mean by
that is people think that just because I
can go into a guns if I really wanted to
I can do a gun store right now buy a gun
within two minutes just like that
you can't yeah because you've done all
of the the background see that's the
thing though I'm still going under I'm
undergoing the same processes right so I
go into the store I find a gun I like
this gun I said I want to buy this gun I
fill out the 44s form 4473 which asked
me a series of questions then they take
that information and they submit it to
the FBI database and they do a
background check but it happens
instantly because technology right
people it's interesting because there's
a lot of people who feel like I said
undergo some type of CIA investigation
before I buy a gun the same people who
also hate the government
right so when they the instant aspect of
the background check causes people who
don't know very much about the process
to think that there isn't one right just
because I can buy the gun easily doesn't
mean it was done thoroughly mm-hmm
you know what I'm saying I underwent the
background check there's a system there
they checked it against the system if I
don't have any felonies or anything that
prevents me from owning that firearm I'm
allowed to buy the gun okay so when
people say there are there are no
background checks and Matt ground checks
aren't tight enough or however you want
to extract that is there any credence to
any of that bit so now let's talk so I
think what you're what you're kind of
going into is the universal background
checks right so when they say universal
back now they do conflate these
terminologies there's the universal
background check is a very specific
statement it's it's not like saying coke
right because people here universal
background checks and other here's the
background check part that Universal
means something and what that means is
it's a requirement that on every single
transaction you have to undergo a
background check even private
transactions right so right now in
California if I had a gun right I can
bring a gun into California I just can't
carry it but like you were like hey you
know Conner I like that gun you have
right what I buy for me in California I
can't sell it to you mm-hmm
right now what here's what I can do I
could say all right cool when I get back
to Texas I'll transfer the gun to a gun
store here in California if it's on the
specific list that allows you to
actually own that gun right because
California has exactly yeah and then you
would have to go to the gun store and
then buy it right now let's say I
decided to give you the gun anyway
privately right now in this room no one
else is here but you and I and I sell do
you've a gun let me show the cameras oh
yeah I mean you know I don't have any
plans on going to jail but and I sell
you the gun you and then let's say you
have the gun
what is there - checked against what
database is there to check against
determine whether or not you got a
background check for that gun now just
completely two issues right now yeah
yeah so well if we get it on the DL
there there's no there's no way and
that's what the whole concept of the
universal background check is it is to
require a background check for every
private transaction
now legally right now I can't do it but
like in Texas I can sell a gun to a
friend and as long as I know he's not a
prohibited person and I know he's not a
felon I can sell him that gun no
problems that's completely legal what
the universal background check idea
suggests is I should have I should be
required to undergo a background check
before I can sell in that gun now I mean
you and he and I would have to go to a
gun store and undergo a background check
then he can go and buy the gun from me
so is the problem with the way it is
currently saying Texas the way you're
describing that you just would not know
potentially enough information about the
person you were selling yes that that's
a potential absolutely and so the reason
why I'm against the universal background
check is because there is no other way
to enforce it but for a national gun
registry because otherwise you have
nothing to check it against right to say
if I if a cop walks down the street says
you have a gun he's like do your
background check for the gun yeah how's
he gonna prove otherwise unless there's
a national registry then it was okay
fine well then let's have a national
registry no because we've seen time and
time again and when the government's
have a national registry of firearms
they subsequently use it to confiscate
guns now the problem is when you say
that they try to put the tinfoil hat on
you right except because what they what
they envision is you know roaring Clark
black military trucks coming down the
street pulling guns from people's houses
no that's not what happens or how they
do it it's constructive and then when
you have potential presidential
candidates like Hillary Clinton
suggesting we should take apart we
should take up the Australia model which
did that very thing they use the
national they use a national gun
registration to tell people to say you
know what you need to turn in your guns
it's a voluntary buyback mmm no it's an
in the mandatory buyback right so and if
you don't sell your guns back guess what
you go to jail that's a confiscation
yeah it's a constructive confiscation
but a compensation nonetheless just
because they didn't roll the military
trucks down the street and pull them out
of your house doesn't mean it isn't
confiscation and so that's why I'm I'm
adamantly against universal background
check
unless you can demonstrate away from me
for it to be applied in such a way that
would not require gun registry because I
do not trust my government not to
exploit that registry in their favor
yeah so how much of this then because
we've talked about it you said to me
right before we started you're sort of a
libertarian I think it's exactly he said
I don't want to put worry about how much
of this does go back to that states
should be able to make the decisions
that they see fit I mean I suspect you
probably wouldn't be that thrilled
living in California other than the
weather I I'm here in California whether
the woman from yeah that's pretty good
food textile yeah we do yeah I'm I
complain about that so see that's just
it too it's like well how far those
states rights go from the standpoint of
violating my Second Amendment right
right
I believe in states rights right at some
point you start violating my
constitutional ones and so when you have
places like California which I think I
think I'm being currently violated now
the fact that I can't carry my my gun
what what is the difference I can take
my I can take my car with my Texas
license and drive it right into
California no one has a problem with
that
I can drive up and down these roads and
as fast as I want as recklessly as I
want yeah that might be illegal but I
still do it does that potentially do it
but yet I can't carry the thing that I
carry to protect my life with the same
license does it make some sense to me
like am i any in any less danger here
then I would be in Texas if anything I
can make the argument that I'm more
there's more danger for me here and that
I don't know the area very well so in a
weird way you're actually making an on
states rights argument here because if
you're saying you want the same thing
everywhere that's a that's not a states
rights argument it's not that but that's
what I'm saying
yeah because but that that's under the
guise of me feeling like me not being
able to carry as a violation of my
constitutional right right because
states rights doesn't allow them to
violate those constitutional rights and
that's that's the argument I'm making
now it's difficult because then you
start talking about the idea of having a
uniform like concealed carry platform
right where one license allows you to
carry a gun everywhere right then you
start getting into weeds but okay well
that's violating states rights that's
only if you don't see my ability to care
firearm as a as a sari my ability carry
firearm as a violation of my
constitutional right right so it's an
interesting philosophical place to talk
because it's like it just depends where
you start yeah because even though I'm
definitely a states rights guy I hear
what you say there and then on the other
hand as a states rights guy to me if a
state wants to have stricter laws and
you're a big gun guy than you actually
are allowed to leave it's kind of as I
would say for virtually every other
situation it's kind of shitty it doesn't
feel great to have to leave a place that
you want to be at but if they're doing
things as part of their state experiment
that you don't like well time it's on
you to get gone yeah but if that same
state creates a law that violates my
right to privacy right well we have
constitutional right that's super see so
I see so I get I get a chair are we
missing anything else on the technical
front because we did that pretty calm or
you see from a mechanical state right
yeah just from the mechanical standpoint
or just any of the language that we use
related to this okay okay so yeah so
then of course there's some people can
say it's trivial some people say it's
not so the magazine versus clip it's
yeah the general terms it's actually
it's called the magazine a clip is an
actual thing it's just different from a
magazine that that's kind of slightly
trivial but it does typically kind of
expose people who don't really know much
about guns
when you say clip versus magazine
because the proper terminology would be
magazine as far as any other mechanical
components yeah well what do I need to
know about the magazine well that's just
terminology it is semantics yeah right I
don't always go about correcting people
because I feel like it just creates
something it kind of makes me look like
an ass but that's why we're doing it
yeah and I want to clean somehow the
biggest thing is it's just the assault
weapon thing right because the ar-15 is
a civilian weapon it's it's designated
the biggest difference between an ar-15
and an assault rifle is that the assault
rifle is fully automatic and they are 15
isn't that's the biggest distinction
between the two now of course then you
can make the argument well that's some
very minor distinction you know there
are a lot of people who make that
argument
but I don't look at the ar-15 any
differently than I look at the handgun
in that sense okay so every time when
one of these happens and we hear the
ar-15 is a weapon of war solo handguns
you would basically put the ar-15 in the
handgun in the same category yes as
pulling one's
schieben ones yeah so that would not be
categorized as a weapon of war we'll see
that's the data destination that
terminology is designed to to manipulate
the emotions of people who don't know
anything about guns so when you hear if
you don't know anything about firearms
and you hear he's the weapon of war
technically speaking all guns or weapons
of war right swords can be weapons
exactly yeah so but what that does
mentally like they understand language
very well yeah they like they're like
not human but in terms of the I call it
the anti-gun side of it of things they
understand the use of language very well
and and they confuse it purposely so
when you hear someone who doesn't know
anything about firearms think about it
like if if I'm already kind of I'm a
little scared of firearms and then I
hear he used a weapon of war what image
comes up in your mind it's it's Rambo
you know he's running down there just
going crazy and that's exactly what he's
doing
but he could do the same thing with a
handgun and so the biggest thing that I
like to when I'm having these
conversations with peoples you're gonna
walk away with you can walk away with
two with two points two trains of
thoughts I'm either gonna get you to
admit you just want to ban all guns or
you can see my perspective because if
you if you're willing to say you know
what we need to get rid of all this salt
weapons as they as they understand them
to be which is essentially ar-15s but
now it's actually becoming more broader
like me to get rid of all semi-automatic
weapons right that's virtually every
modern gun so let's say they move they
want to ban ar-15s ar-15 rifles aren't
even used like the percentage that
rifles are used in actual shootings is
so low and marginal it's unreal so then
why are we focusing on it but okay then
what are most shootings
guns yeah right so if you get rid of
that and we got rid of ar-15 and then we
have another shooting happening because
the are loves deadly school mass
shooting was Virginia Tech and he used a
hangar so then what happens if that
happens again so now what are you gonna
ban you gonna ban handgun and that's
when you're stuck having to confront the
fact that okay either you really just
want to ban all guns or you understand
that the distinction is irrelevant
right we've got to get to the absolute
point of issue and why these things are
happening and focusing on the gun is
doing a disservice to the conversation
it sounds like I'm just utilizing I'm
using a bigger issue as a scapegoat but
in reality if you really sit down and
think about it all right we have over
300 close to 400 million guns in this
country they're not going anywhere
mm-hmm and understanding that you've got
to then sit down and say to yourself all
right if we're gonna try to fix this
issue of gun violence or just violence
in general we've got to get to the root
of the issue of why people are doing it
and then understanding that staying
within the context of reality we've got
to understand well in the process I
still have to protect myself and because
people are still still gonna be able to
get their hands on guns whether legal or
not and and use them to commit crimes in
the brain people's lives I've got to be
put in a situation to defend against
that so you can ban all the ar-15 what
doesn't mean it's gonna stop somebody
from getting one on a black market so
now yes I don't run from the fact that
the ar-15 is a more powerful platform
that I agree with and I don't think I
don't run from that they're gonna be
people on who are gonna be mad at me for
saying that but the reason why don't
ruffle mint is because that's the very
reason why I want an ar-15 when it comes
to defending my life I don't want it to
be a fair fight mm-hm
period I don't want to have to confront
someone with an ar-15 with the handgun
if I don't have to if you come in my
house I'm not grabbing a handgun I'm
grabbing an ar-15
see we have this strange thing it's like
when people will say okay well the
Second Amendment is the right to bear
arms and then they'll put up a picture
of you know the type of arms that
existed way back when and and it's like
well then we should be have the right to
that because that's what they were
talking about it like this is so
disingenuous
very disingenuous it's like they were
also talking about why you should be
able to form a militia and it's like the
thing that we'd be fighting against now
has a lot more power and it doesn't mean
that just because you have some guns
you're gonna be able to stop the guys in
the black trucks as you talked about
earlier but maybe you could defend
yourself a little bit longer and who
knows what happens with a little bit of
time I mean wouldn't be true but they're
still fighting in Afghanistan and those
guys over there just using ak-47s you
know what I'm saying so like we can't
just because we're gonna lose there
something you just lie down and do it
mmm you know and in the hope that the
whole notion of like I'm an ID selector
trying to thought the this idea of
owning firearms to combat the government
it's they think it's preposterous but
I'm like ask the people in Venezuela
what's going on and again these are now
the people at least in this current
moment people who say that the
government is run by our engine Hitler
exactly and it really well well this is
a good spot to I think change some minds
and as I said to you before we sat down
I've never considered myself a gun
person per se I'm interested I'm always
interested in talking about these things
but I do find myself now more pro-gun
it's probably not even the right phrase
to say yeah then I've ever been in my
life and that but that for me it has
more to do with that I'm really
understanding what rights are in a much
clearer way and and what I want the
government to do and not undo and once
you understand that then you know it's
tough it's tough to take other positions
it is weak so is there anything to you
that when they always say sensible gun
control and I always see the the pro-gun
people will say well the people that
always say that just don't know what
they're talking about it and I sense
you're probably in that spot cuz that
you would just say do with language yeah
so sensible gun control most of some
people say that they actually advocating
zwi already have background checks
things of that nature right and then you
like and you have other language like
the loop the gun show your gun your gun
show loophole yeah let's talk about
that's not a loophole all that all that
is is a private transaction that's all
that is and it's just happening
happening it just
to happen at a gun show if you bought a
gun from an actual dealer at a gun show
you still have to undergo a background
check so the when they say loophole what
we're saying is that if you are at a gun
show you're not a dealer yeah you can
actually sell that gun at if you are if
one the person is not a prohibited
possessor you're from the same state
then yes okay if there's nothing that
precludes them from owning a firearm
legally I can sell them a gun at a gun
show right so the only slippery part of
that is what we talked about earlier
which is you just may not know all the
information exactly so there is a there
is I guess there's a little bit of a
gray area and that one is that affair in
terms of you yeah that you're sort of
taking somebody's word for it at that
point
let's meet somebody that day and they're
like I want to buy that gun and you say
to that you ask them all the appropriate
questions they could be lying to you
absolutely but that's just there but
then that so then the way the response
that they have to that is the universe a
background check but as I pointed out
how do you how do you enforce it without
a national registry and in with that
national registry even with the national
registry
it doesn't stop anything right we tend
to go down this I just road of just
wanting to do things to make ourselves
feel better but in reality name one mass
shooting that would have been prevented
with a universal background check now
one because even the people who had guns
who weren't supposed to have them they
got them illegally mm-hmm right it
wasn't because there wasn't a universal
background check that stopped them from
getting it no it was it so I had so I
have to ask the question I thought then
why are we doing this other didn't just
to make ourselves feel better because
it's literally doing nothing nothing and
so that's why like the person who bought
and sold a gun privately at a at a gun
show could done that in the parking lot
of the gun show could have done it at
their house before going to the gun show
you get what I'm saying yeah but what it
does is when you frame it within the
context of the gun show loophole it
makes it seem like it's this bizarre
where everyone comes there together and
sells illegal guns right that's that
image that's created in mind I think
it's Bartertown
like to feed on the they feed on the
ignorance of people yeah right because
like they're not everybody knows that
much about guns it's it's like it's one
of those things like I don't know I
don't know a lot about a lot of other
things that people may know a lot about
right so if you tell me something and
I'm not really researched and schooled
on that issue you can get me to believe
some pretty kooky stuff yeah and that's
what I'm talking about is what you
consistently see at any time we talked
about this and you know there's this
other piece of it where it's like every
time a shooting happened you know
there's this pylon where oh now now we
should talk about it and then there's
this other part of us where it's because
we go from one crisis to another that
there's never really seems to me at this
point we never really have time to
really ever fully unpack any of these
things I think I think there's moments
like this but on a national level we're
not particularly good at these
conversation no cuz then what it does it
just turns into a political sparring
match yeah I mean right after the last
shooting and when Dana lotion and Rubio
were on that CNN Town Hall I mean it was
it was meaningful to me in the
gladiatorial fast it was a disaster was
everything I hate about just the quick
bites and all of this and flashiness and
just thinking we take out right now it
was a disaster and then and I said and I
pointed this out how can we have a real
honest conversation when they try to
paint pro-gun people as crazy when we
say no the ultimate goal is to ban guns
but then I can watch a CNN live Town
Hall where Ruby will suggest you do
realize banning all semi-automatic guns
is essentially banning all guns and the
entire stadium erupts and applause and
cheers yeah so then I go yo Rubio said
exactly what you said and they started
cheering even even when confronted with
the core because Rubio said look you
want a ban on semi-automatic guns here
let me educate you really quickly and
tell you that's virtually all guns so
even when he corrected them so it wasn't
they can't they can't they can't claim
they were ignorant on it because he just
explained to them that means banning
virtually all guns and they upped it so
it goes okay so now you have all those
programs alike right you're just gonna
go back to our
there's and there's no discussion
because while while we're trying to be
fair your ultimate goal is to try to ban
them all you know there was that moment
I'm sure you remember this after the
parkland shooting when they had the big
rally and one of the survivors got up
there and said we're gonna come what was
the line you remember the exact line
where she said basically we're gonna
come for the semi automatics you now but
we're gonna come for everything later
something to that effect them yeah I'm
slightly butchering it but I thought wow
no now you're flat out saying and you're
just giving you're telling them now so I
could see why you know I see this with
all my frustrations when they left all
the time it's like I know they're never
gonna stop I've seen it so consistently
and that's why I'm staking out some
positions but sometimes it's it's kind
of sucky to have to just be like well
the people that I'm fighting against how
to speak they're not dealing in the same
world that I'm dealing in and I and that
makes it more important for me to stake
out a position but the thing that's most
frustrating about it is the way they'll
color it in the mainstream media is that
we're unreasonable we don't want to move
on inch we've dug her heels in all we
want is to be you don't care about
anything and really what it is is no I
let you into my house
and now you're trying to take my house
from me so get out just as essentially
what they're saying is all right so
they'll say well common sense that's all
we hate that were common sense because
it because it's disingenuous it's like
well we need common-sense measures after
our shooting all right and another
shooting happens we need more
common-sense measures and another
student happens we need even more
common-sense measures when does
common-sense measures stop being common
sense and just intruding on my rights
yeah and I can see the you know you know
my thing for guns to use free speech to
me and it's like I can see this coming
with that if these guys took control
you'd start seeing well we could have
free speech but we need some
common-sense controls around Breezer
actually so I so I do understand the
position like I tell people all the time
I'm like there are over 300 federal gun
laws in this country I think we've been
reasonable I think we were really truly
being unreasonable we wouldn't have over
there
I can't begin to tell you how many we
have on a state level right so it's
incredibly disingenuous to think that
we're just being hard hard-asses who
don't want to move on inch on the issue
right no one's saying it should be a
free-for-all where we're just handing
out guns to everyone like Oprah right I
don't think anybody has a problem
inherently with background checks now
when talking my universal background
checks that's a different thing but
since nobody since they never want to
make that distinction right no one ever
knows that you can't you can't exactly
and then the idea of like you know we
can talk about gun-free zones right and
it begs the questions like what is that
what is that sticker on when they're
gonna do for me so now I have to make
like people don't really like to
sympathize with gun owners in the sense
of like we all want the same result
right we want the killing the stop we
want the violence to stop notice I said
violence and killing not just gun
violence right because we can't just
focus on gun violence because violence
is violence however you died you died
and it's bad all the way around but when
I have to make a decision about whether
or not I potentially break a law to go
into an establishment that may or may
not cause me to need my gun at some
point and that's messed up and I know
that there are a lot of people who don't
see it that way because they don't see
value in the Second Amendment because
they're not firearm owners right there
are a lot of people who look at the
Second Amendment is useless because they
don't own firearms but when you have a
group of people who understand the
importance of it and how it fits into
their lives and they understand that at
the end of the day when something
happens the only person who's gonna be
there to stop it is you that's a big
deal so it's not just me trying to
protect a piece of metal because I just
want to have fun with my guns
no it's much bigger than that it's this
idea that I have to rely on myself you
can tell me all day long the police are
gonna be there the police are gonna be
there but they're not going to be there
just not and then you can you name we're
at Heartland exactly right
so then you can you add kids family into
the mix that ratchet it up to a whole
nother level so about what about the
piece of this that just sort of optics
so you know every now and again
see a picture of like three dudes with
big-ass guns at Chipotle you know like
an open carry now I know if I was if I
walked into Chipotle and three guys came
in with big-ass guns on their back yeah
okay well I would take noise and I
probably leave but I probably would I
would just be like you know looking
again I'm here I'm there in California
where that would be so bad
so out of the door but let's but for the
person that's living in Texas no home
can do this if I was in Chipotle right
and three guys well then I probably
would leave no one everything that you
just said they're knowing that these
guys are probably NRA members and and as
far as I know no NRA member has ever
done a mass you know right okay so you
know cuz you see this all tiny
celebrities Michael Ian Black like ad on
the show who's on this rampage telling
everyone that you guys are terrorists I
mean really that you're you're part of a
terrorist organization I mean okay and
so are the five million members right
but I but I think there is something
about some of the optics a minute you
know I mean like I would be nervous now
I get your point would be well those
guys are gonna protect you when the
other guy walks in or whatever then some
of that may be feelings over facts right
there but it just it just is there
interesting thing about it that is a big
debate within the gun the gun community
as a whole the idea of open carry vers
concealed carry i don't ever open carry
except for maybe if I'm out hunting or a
mountain range or something like that i
but that's that's a personal decision
I'm choosing my own for various reasons
one sometimes I rather not have the
attention and tactically I like the
advantage of having the element of
surprise you don't know I have a gun on
me so if I had to use it I'm going to be
reacting alright I'm not going into a
place to shoot it up if somebody decides
to come into a place to shoot about I'm
gonna be reacting to that so I need all
the advantages I get from my personal
perspective so I want the element of
surprise there's some people who think
in the alternative they feel like just a
mere presence of that gun is a deterrent
from anyone who wants to come in and do
some bad so if guys casing out a couple
stores and indicies there are certain
citizens in there with long guns and
some that have handguns on the side of
the hip then that's a deterrent right
I understand the alarm that people who
don't necessarily engage in interact
with firearms get when they see people
walking around with rifles right even I
thought there been I've seen a couple of
people in Texas do it and initially my
gut reaction and I'll admit it was like
what's going on here
now I'm very verse firearms and I have a
gun too so at that point I actually
almost welcome it and the reason why is
because if you're going to do something
I now get to see you attempt to do it
you get what I'm saying there's a
telegraph you are in a unique case on
this one yes
but I'm speaking from purely a place of
personal yea preference right
am i tweaking on the whole for anyone
else things like that me personally I
would rather like to know you have it
right if I can see it because then I
know where to focus my attention versus
me kind of being alone to a state of
complacency because of its absence and
then all of a sudden somebody stands up
and decides he wants to shoot the place
up and then I have to react to that but
again that's tactics right that's that's
this personal preference in that regard
however I do understand the alarm that
somebody would have seen three guys
walking to Chipotle with the with rifles
because it seems seemingly especially to
them they seems like that's a bit
excessive
a lot of you if I can conceal carry a
rifle I would because it's better at
defending me than a handgun was the only
reason the only reason I have a handgun
is because a small enough for me to
conceal any Indian allows me to live my
life and uninterrupted otherwise I'd
walk around with a rifle okay so we
can't end without doing sort of what I
think would be the big question for
everything we've talked about here and
for someone that works with the NRA and
your shows on NRA TV and all that so
what is going on in America right now
that seems to be unique to our society
we do have more shootings here than I
then I think virtually all other Western
nations combined so okay for you to fact
check me on that advice don't read that
one but but it does seem it's and even
if I'm slightly oh no you're good it
seems that there is something uniquely
happening here now I would argue that
there's all sorts of mental health
issues and probably prescription drugs
and maybe non prescription drugs and all
sorts other stuff
so there's a couple of things so I'll
try to I'll try to keep this as concise
as possible cuz we are gonna get into
weeds for its lit second yeah so first
of all let's talk about mass shootings
right here school school and so for
instance I recently just read a study
from Northwestern University
that's one ago which talked about
comparing the number of school and
shootings
back in the 90s versus the vs. today and
what they concluded essentially was the
perception is that it's happening more
frequently but it's not it's actually on
par or even less now than it was then
now you can people who can oh my god how
could you possibly say that google it
it's a Northwestern University research
a camera with the actual title of their
actual research but we're gonna grab it
from you after this and guys link to it
in absolutely so that being said mass
shootings account for a very very very
marginal percentage of shootings in this
country let's start off with the overall
so thirty five thirty five to thirty six
thousand people each year die from guns
right I didn't specify gun violence but
just guns because they don't do that
that was it's a gun violence right so
sixty about 16 to 65 percent of those
that 35,000 is suicides now what I'm not
saying is we don't care about suicides
we do however when it comes to the idea
and the issue of somebody shooting at me
mm-hmm that's that's not it's not
germane yeah but then even still if you
want to make the argument well if we had
less guns we'd have less suicides that's
also not true because our suicide rate
is on par with every other major country
so if it was the case that the more guns
you have the more suicides we'd be
leading the charge we don't where
there's a will there's a way
exactly Yeah right even some of the more
famous suicides we've had they didn't
use guns so we set that number side
which is a huge number
yeah sixty-five percent it's a huge
number out of thirty five thirty six
thousand so then you have about one to
three percent which are justifiable
homicides that's self-defense that's
including police shooting criminals who
are shooting at them right and people
who use guns in self-defense right you
gotta set that aside because that's not
the issue we're trying to address so set
that number side and then you have about
five
which are accidental right kid gets
finds a gun pull triggers unfortunate
extremely unfortunate however I believe
personally half of that it could easily
be addressed with more education so if
we took the energy that we took that we
place now I'm trying to vilify guns and
have national campaigns teaching people
about gun safety that will cut that
number in half because a lot of these
accidents are easily preventable but
they're just people who have guns too
just don't know hmm and so if we spent
time educating those people do we know
what percentage of that subset is
getting those guns legally or illegally
because I would imagine that a lot of
it's probably illegal which is why they
don't know how to use the gun in the
first I'm not gonna assume I have that
answer because I don't have that hard
number yeah but and I would bet I do
feel comfortable assuming that as well
yeah right and so if we take that
accidents to set that aside purely
homicides we're looking at around seven
to ten thousand every year right now
that's a different looking number right
well movie accounted for all the context
here with those those other shootings
now the vast majority I say close to 80
percent of red and a couple of articles
of those homicides are happening in the
inner cities of our country all right so
then reason goes all right so let's look
at those inner cities and look at the
dynamics there right you have low jobs
lack of Economic Opportunity destroyed
households and Anarkali Kanna me that
warrants that warrants but creates
necessity for this type of violence so
if we dealt with the socio-economic
aspects of what's going on in those
areas right do we really have a gun
problem just think about it I know I
know other communities fill with black
people they have guns they don't have
the same level of violence cuz I only
say black people because most people
associate the inner city with
with black people right but the reason
why we have that high level of
concentration of violence it's because
of the conditions in those environments
and even within those communities there
are the vast majority of people in those
communities are good people and it's a
very minor group of people with creating
a large number of the violence right so
there's something to be said do we
really have a gun problem or do we have
a socio-economic suicide problem in this
country because at the end of the day
there's 35 to 36 thousand that people
assuming is all gun violence by way of
homicides people shooting at other
people to kill them it's not the case
we're looking at close to the seven and
ten thousand if that and so if you take
those numbers and you compare in other
countries then how does it look to be
continued yeah well I'm so glad that we
finally did this and we will definitely
do this again because I absolutely this
story and and everything we've talked
about here is just gonna continue I mean
these are the battles that we're now
fighting on many fronts related to the
Constitution and free speech and free
expression and your ability to to own
your life and all that stuff and that's
all we ask is that this is let me put in
one say one last thing people there are
a lot of people who was like wow how do
you feel the need to carry a gun why I
like the chances of you needing to use
that gun to protect yourself one percent
and the answer I have for that is this
you may be right
chance' me need to care to actually use
my gun defend myself maybe you really
slim maybe 1% but if that 1% happens
it's a hundred percent of everything the
consequences are a hundred percent and
that's why it's so important yeah all
right well that's how you end a show you
know you maybe will do this next time
maybe we'll bring you on with someone on
some of the other side of the issues on
things I will tell them what have that
conversation sounds like a plan all
right for more on colione check them out
on twitter mr. colleano are
[Music]